you have uh you have a few videos on
this but how does a rocket engine work
uh you've you're wearing some of the
instruction manuals but uh for one one
type of it like what what's the fuel
what are the kind of types of different
rockets that you can kind of give an
overview yeah ultimately a rocket engine
converts
um high pressure and heat into kinetic
energy like that's the only real job of
a rocket engine is to take uh high
pressure gas hot high pressure gas
um very energized there's a lot of
energy involved and then literally
turning that into
molecules shooting in One Direction into
kinetic energy
so um yeah what you do basically you
know I mean the simplest version of it
is of course like famously a balloon you
take a balloon you fill it up with air
you've got a pressure you let go of it
uh some of the air shoots out in a
general direction-ish you converted that
pressure into kinetic energy now if you
start scaling that up
um you know you can continue to do
something like that like um cold gas
Thruster would be kind of the most
simple and easiest rocket engine to make
would be a cold gas Thruster and all
that is you literally just take air or
specifically nitrogen because it's a
little bit more dense than all the
others or you know and it's the majority
of our atmosphere
um you can uh or sorry it's more sparse
you can condense that down shorten a
really high pressure bottle and then uh
just literally shoot it through what's
called a d level nozzle which is
something that chokes the flow a little
bit gets it to be
um takes it and gets it into supersonic
speeds once it's at supersonic speed you
actually can't choke it down anymore
you'll just constrict the flow of of
mass flow constrict the airflow so you
actually go opposite you start making it
wider and once it's already at
supersonic speeds if you expand it and
make it wider it actually gets faster
and faster so at first you know when
it's subsonic gas you start shrinking
you can strict the flow you know it's
actually speeding up just like you know
a highway if you go from you know or any
of these examples like a water hose you
you know if you pinch it down you want
to flow the same amount of water from
point A to point B through a smaller
pipe you can you can flow more water or
the same amount of water from point A to
point B with a smaller pipe it just has
to go faster so obviously you can
constrict it but at some point you
actually get to a physical limitation
and that happens to be the speed of
sound once it gets to the local speed of
sound
you can then actually do the opposite
you actually expand it back out and
you're continuing to convert
um the the pressure into velocity at
that point but it's now Supersonic and
what's interesting is while you're doing
that you're actually cooling it down too
each each bit of that pipe that you're
making wider and wider and wider you're
cooling down so the more heat energy you
have to work with the more work you can
actually do so at some point a hot high
pressure rocket engine is the best
source of like that's the ultimate
amount of work you can do and the nozzle
so as you're saying there's a bunch of
different design options but it's a
critical part of this yeah how you do
that conversion which is basically like
how much can you convert is really like
the ultimate game how much pressure and
heat can we convert into thrust like
that's really at the end of the day
that's what a rocket engine is so you
have to have a powerful enough rocket
engine to actually lift the rocket and
we'll rocket is mostly just fuel it's
like 90 90 plus percent just the weight
of fuel so you just have to lift the
fuel that's going to take it
uh you know into orbit and that's the
thing specifically for Rockets you're
just saying generally rocket engines but
for the task of going to orbit you're
Fighting Gravity Earth gravity which is
fundamentally different than moon
gravity or yeah Mars gravity yeah uh or
like you said traveling out the space
Earth has a pretty intense
gravity it's to overcome we're lucky
because if I think if it's ten percent
either way like 10 harder it'd be like
oh we could still do it you know we'd
still be with our current technology
we'd still be able to get stuff into
orbit man things like reusability and
this you know commercialization the
success that we've seen in the last 10
years it would just be on two thinner
margins I think 10 easier and we would
have been like I mean it's just like
totally different it's so much it's so
much easier it's like this big you know
sliding scale and 10 in either direction
we'd be either screwed or really happy
you know as far as getting in his face
so it's just hard enough that it things
like fully reusable becomes very very
very difficult I think it's completely
achievable we have all the pieces to
make it achievable does not disobey any
laws of physics it does not disobey any
there's no like hard stops it's just
very very very hard and so ultimately
yeah like on Earth for the first bit of
launch again when the Rocket's pointing
straight up and it and the engines are
pointing straight down pointy end up
play me and down you're Fighting Gravity
and so that's kind of your biggest enemy
outside of the Earth's atmosphere too so
what kind of uh sources of fuel is there
so this chemical Rockets liquid solid
gas hybrid uh there's electric so what
what are the kinds of fuels we're
talking about what are oxidizes what
what can you just explain your shirt I
guess
yeah
so uh so really I mean fuels it's
there's kind of two terms we'll you'll
generally hear the word propellant being
used as anything that is used to propel
a spacecraft or used in a rocket engine
so
um you have to have you know you can
have a fuel here you have to have a fuel
you have to have an oxidizer and you
have to have a spark to actually get
those things burning and that's just a
general law of like the universe you
have to have fuel and oxidizer in a
spark
um now some fuels will by themselves
spark like hypergolic fuels But
ultimately you're always left with some
kind of fuel oxidizer and a spark so um
the the general ones used most often in
Rockets liquid oxygen is kind of the
king of well there's better oxidizers
but they're extremely extremely hard to
work with like fluorine
um but the generally liquid oxygen so
you just chill oxygen down to its liquid
state minus 183 degrees Celsius so it
can be dense enough to store in tanks
you know it's a thousand times more
dense when it's in liquid than it is as
a gas
rp1 which is basically kerosene is a
very common fuel
another common fuel nowadays is methane
liquid methane liquid hydrogen is
another it's the most efficient
potential for the most efficient since
it's one of the lightest molecules so I
think correct me if I'm wrong but Falcon
9 uses kerosene and then uh Starship
uses methane because methane yep for
fuel and they both use liquid oxygen for
their oxidized for the oxidizer okay yep
um but then you know if you get into
hypergolics you'll normally have
nitrogen tetroxide which is your
oxidizer and some form of hydrazine
for your fuel
there's solid rocket propellants like
solid rocket boosters and those are
actually pre-mixed your oxidizer is
inherently like baked literally like
kind of baked into the sludge of of fuel
so like for SpaceX it's all uh chemical
liquid fuels yep yep so how many solid
base uh fuels are there is that are they
still being used today is there most
Rockets yeah and the United States
really is the only ones that well the
only ones I guess early on because it
was really just the Soviet Union versus
the United States the United States
started to use solids pretty early on uh
they're simple and easy but these days
like you know you'll still see them kind
of as traditionally like boosters like
they're used to just uh help get
something off the ground or help give it
a little extra boost
um so the space shuttle famously had
those two huge white solid rocket
boosters attached to the orange fuel
tank those are solid rocket repellents
um things like the atlas 5 can have up
to five smaller solid rocket boosters
there's very few rockets that use a Pure
uh at least these days they use a Pure
solid rocket motor for its first stage
um there still are especially in China
there's a lot of startup rocket
companies that kind of use just missile
technology you know they might use like
a they might just be a variant of an
ICBM
um that just use solid rocket fuel
because it is very relatively easy to
develop you know model rockets use solid
rocket Motors and stuff like that so
they're they're still around but they're
just not as elegant and not as uh yeah
not as as used these days so uh what are
rocket engine Cycles again I think
getting more to you towards your shirt
question you have a really good video
called that uh I mean a lot of your
videos that are technical are just
exceptionally well done so I just I
think
um
you deserve all the props you get I mean
thank you for for doing this work really
really really really well done uh so
it's called rocket engine Cycles how do
you power a rocket engine and you go
through all the different options is
there something you could say about uh
open cycle close cycle full flow
um all the different variants that you
can use words to explain yeah without
all the pretty pictures yeah without the
pretty pictures so ultimately you know
like we said we your ultimate goals you
want to get heat and pressure
into an engine so obviously at some
point you can either make really thick
tanks of your rocket you can like get it
so thick that you store the propellants
in at really really high pressures but
obviously like that doesn't scale very
well at some point your Rocket's so
heavy you can't even leave the ground or
you know it's just you so much of your
mass is just literally the walls of the
rocket so at some point people realize
hey we could actually just pump the
fuels and the oxidizer into the engine
at a high pressure and increase the
pressure through a pump now obviously a
pump is going to require energy you have
to get that energy from somewhere
um and again at some point people were
like well Rockets are
there's already Rocket Fuel here you
know we'll just use some of the energy
from the rocket fuel to spin these pumps
so that that would be considered like
open cycle closed cycle full flow stage
combustion Cycles are are ways to
tap into the propellant actually and
then there's tap off expanders like I
mean all of them kind of do the same
thing but you end up at some point
spinning a turbine uh you know a turbine
can take uh some of the heat energy and
the and the and the pressure
uh of an engine and then they can that
can be connected to a shaft to pumps and
those pumps can you know increase the
pressure of the propellants
and force it into the combustion chamber
now the difference between open cycle
closed cycle full flaw all those is what
happens
after the gas has flown through the
turbine so after you've used the turbine
and spun up the energy you know spun up
the engine what happens to that gas so
in an open cycle engine you basically
have like a separate small rocket engine
in a sense it's a gas generator they
call it and that will be used to create
someone you know take a little we'll say
10 of your the propellant flowing to the
engine instead you reroute it to like a
smaller rocket engine called the gas
generator you point that at your turbine
and that will spin your turbine up to
you know ridiculous speed it's 30 000
plus RPM and then after it spins it's
wasted most of its its energy you know
and it's just dumped overboard that
would be open cycle you're not worrying
about it after that point but you are
left with a lot of unburnt un you know
unused fuel a good amount of that fuel
is just completely and especially
because the turbine uh you you have to
keep it from melting so you can't run it
at like Optimal
ratios not necessarily stoichiometric
and a rocket engine you actually don't
want it to be near stoichiometric where
you're releasing all the energy you
actually want to release
um you actually want to be throwing out
the lighter molecule so it can be shot
out faster generally in the engine so um
but in order to have a turbine survive
you have to actually cool you have to
have the gas going through it it can't
be stupid stupid hot or else you're just
going to melt your turbine so they
normally um especially in the open cycle
you just run it really fuel Rich so
there's a lot of extra fuel being pumped
into it that will keep the temperatures
at a reasonable
uh you know at a reasonable temperature
so you end up with this like dark [__]
smoke pouring out of that gas generator
that's just unburned fuel it's just
wasted fuel it never got a chance to be
used oh interesting you know like in the
combustion chamber it's not it's not
being used to propel the rocket you know
it's just being used to cool down the
the propellant that's being used to spin
the turbine that's being used to spin
the pumps to push a lot of propellant
into the engine
so
you know it doesn't take too long before
you know your a greedy rocket scientist
being like look at all this wasted
propellant all this potential energy
that's just literally being spewed out
the side of the rocket so that's where
the closed cycle comes in so now we have
to get that propellant take it from
basically
what was being wasted through the
turbine and you're going to try pumping
it back into the engine now you don't
literally just pump that that gas that's
you know that hot that gas into the
engine because it's actually way too low
of pressure uh compared to the main
combustion chamber by that point by the
time has gone through the turbine it's
lost most of its pressure and heat to
the turbine so if you tried pumping it
into the engine you know just taking
that pipe and sticking it right into the
combustion chamber that the much higher
pressure hotter combustion chamber would
just go backwards and it'd stall out the
engine and blow up the engine and
whatever what have you so what they
actually do is they normally will send
there might be some variations of this
but the general concept is you actually
flow all of your fuel or all of your
oxidizer through the turbine so that
would be closed cycle so there's fuel
Rich closed cycle which would be your
flowing all of the fuel through the
turbine or there's oxidizer closed cycle
which is where you're flowing all of the
oxidizer that's going into the engine
through the turbine now the trick here
is you have to have that turbine after
it's done its work so after it's taken
some of the potential energy some of the
heat energy from we're now calling it a
pre-burner by the way instead of it
being a gas generator you now call that
device that's that's creating pressure
to spin the turbine you're not calling
that a pre-burner because it's just
going to pre-burn some of your fuel or
some of your oxidizer
the trick is that has to be by the time
it's gone through the turbine it has to
be higher pressure
than the combustion chamber because
otherwise it's going to go backwards
still so you really have to get that
pre-burner up to ridiculously high
pressures like at least 20 higher than
your main combustion chamber and these
combustion Chambers you know we're
talking about engines that are at you
know 200 100 to 200 even in spacex's
Raptor engine up to 300 bar in the main
combustion chamber so that's what is
that 4500 PSI basically insane amounts
of of pressure inside these combustion
Chambers so your turbine has to be even
above that or your your gas generator or
your pre-burner sorry has to be higher
pressure than that even in order to have
the flow going the right direction
through the engine
so now you'll you'll have those closed
Cycles you'll have fuel Rich you have
oxidizer Rich
um the tricks now you're starting to get
it's crazy there's just so many
compromises every little decision you
have of like oh I did this now I know
well now crap it's gonna do this for
instance fuel Rich if you ran kerosene
fuel Rich you know how I mentioned soot
coming out of the gas generator well if
you run soot
um
through your through your engine like
that and had it go through your
injectors like back into the engine
it'll clog the pores of the injectors
and it will end up blowing up the engine
the soot itself is so damaging that you
can't really run a fuel-rich kerosene
engine what exactly is so it's like fuel
somehow mixed up with the smoke like
what I wonder what what is it chemically
it's just some weird it's mostly just
carbon it's probably just that carbon
that dark solid solid chunks of carbon
and it can cake up and just literally
like you know like yeah it's it's like
ash almost you know like at some point
you know especially under those High
pressures and high temperatures it can
physically build up and you know turn
into like stalagmites and stalactites of
of carbon really hard
you know for forged in a rocket engine
carbon I wonder how you figure all that
out too is that's the experimentation
some of that has come chemist like
theoretical but like you're gonna have
to build the thing at scale and actually
test the trial and if you're trying here
there's many decades of trial and error
and many pieces of engines that you're
trying to piece back to they're going
like what the hell happened here yeah
what happened yeah okay so uh so that's
closed cycle so how do we get to full
flow so in either of those situations
you're still actually just having the
opposite so if you're fuel Rich you know
all the fuel is going through the
turbine but um only a tiny bit of oxygen
is actually being put into that
pre-burner to spin the pumps and the
rest of the the rest of the oxygen is
actually going through the pump the
primary pump and straight into the
combustion chamber
now full flow the idea is you're going
to actually pre-burn both your
propellants both your propellants are
going to go through a pre-burner and
they're both going to end up spinning
one of the pumps so you'll have a gas a
fuel rich pre-burner and you're going to
have an oxygen-rich pre-burner each one
of those is going to get just you know
they're going to heat it up just enough
and get it up to just enough pressure to
spin up that turbine as fast as they
need to do to get the pumps up to the
right pressure and still have enough
pressure through the turbine to overcome
the pressure inside the main combustion
chamber and they're both going to arrive
both your fuel and your oxidizer are
going to arrive in the main combustion
chamber as hot gases already so what was
liquid oxygen is now gaseous oxygen what
was Liquid methane is now gaseous
methane and they're meeting in this
combustion chamber at still ridiculously
high pressures again
for spacex's uh Raptor engine they're
meeting at 300 bar insane amounts of
pressure and then they uh then they
combust from there on and because
they're already a gas gas interaction
they're happy to burn they're ready to
they're ready to burn they're ready to
mingle as opposed to having a gas liquid
interaction which is what's a lot more
normal you know you'll have two
different states of matter and they just
might not they might take a little more
core you know coaxing to what's that
word
yeah
that doesn't sound like it's not correct
right focusing coaxing yeah yeah all
right I don't know we'll cut that in
post we'll have Morgan Freeman uh over
Davos yeah uh
the fascinating thing is they're coaxed
and there's gases and combustion but
yeah they they just take a little bit
more it takes more time in the
combustion chamber to have a liquid gas
interaction like mixed together and and
re unleash as much of their energy as he
can before it exits the system uh some
of the trade-offs here in terms of
efficiency which which is most efficient
and then also complexity of the design
and the engineering and the cost of the
design and the engineering like what are
the different trade-offs between open
cycle closed cycle and full flow yeah
it's a pretty it's kind of like a
oh what's the the Bears uh the
Goldilocks you know like it's like it
you kind of generally the easiest is
open cycle because you know you're just
expelling the the exhaust gas
um the gas generator exhaust you're not
having to worry about it you just spin
up that thing as much as you need and
deal with it right no big deal
um closed Cycles offers 10 to 15 greater
performance generally because you know
you're not wasting that propellant and
but it's it's complicated it's a lot
more complicated especially if you're
doing oxygen rich now you're having hot
gaseous oxygen uh in your engine which
just generally wants to react with
everything it's just a recipe like hot
oxygen is just a recipe for things to
catch on fire that shouldn't be on fire
so Metals you know under those
conditions lots of times we'll just
spontaneously start burning you know
you'll actually turn your metal and it
will now become fuel you'll be engine
Rich before you know it because you're
hot oxygen nice is uh is eating and
using that engine as fuel basically so
um oxygen rich is generally very hard
but that is what the Soviet Union ended
up doing with almost their entire line
of Vengeance was close cycle oxygen rich
but you know so those two are kind of
generally hard but offer great
performance benefits over open cycle uh
but at the end of the day you know full
flow is by far the it's the ultimate of
all of them it's the most difficult but
it also has the most potential to be the
most efficient Starship the Raptor too
the the why is that engine using full
flow
because it's the best I mean it's just
physics wise if you're trying to extract
as much energy out of your propellants
there there just isn't another cycle
type that that is uh better than it but
of course it's very very hard to develop
you know so far to date the rd270 in the
60s was built
um there is a powerhead demonstrator
built in the United States in the in the
90s and early 2000s I think maybe just
the early 2000s
um that was just the just the power Just
the the pumps and the turbines and the
pre-burners no chamber no nothing that
was a big deal only the United States
took you know millions of dollars to
just develop that and then there's
spacex's Raptor engine so you talked
about uh the combustion chamber and how
damn hot things get high pressure
a lot of heat uh how do you keep the
thing cool you have a great video on
this how do you get it from uh from what
do you call it metal Rich engine Rich
engine Rich from like the the metal from
melting well one of the ways is to let
it be engine Rich there's actually you
can use ablative cooling you can
literally let
um make the walls thicker than you
normally make it make it out of a
material that will ablate away that will
kind of chip away and take some of the
heat away with it it's very again
primitive and it's actually what SpaceX
first used on their first Merlin engines
they used ablative cooling
um so it's basically a carbon nozzle and
you just let it get the carbon the inner
layer of the of the engine was not of
his carbon and you just let it get
chewed away and eaten away and then
that's just something you factor in uh
it's not a very elegant and it's
definitely not reusable in that sense so
there's probably really good models
about like how it melts away the rate at
which melts away to know what thickness
yeah but boy is it dangerous
is part of the design seems so silly so
obviously you probably you know it's
again it's not the most elegant and the
problem too your geometry physically is
changing too because as you're eroding
the walls now things like your expansion
ratio or the ratio between your throat
and the nozzle exit is changing yeah
because the thickness like the throats
diameter is actually like everything is
changing so it's it's not great it might
might not be melting away uniformly
there could be some like weird pockets
for aerodynamic stuff it's just a bunch
of chaos just can which I can't imagine
having to like figure all that stuff out
honestly yeah
um so the uh the more elegant thing to
do there's there's a couple other things
you can do but the kind of the most
common one especially when we're dealing
with liquid field Rockets is something
called regeneratively Cooling and the
the idea is you basically just flow fuel
or fuel or oxidizer through the walls of
the of the nozzle on the chamber
um before they go through like into the
injector or into the actual combustion
chamber by doing that your your taking
heat out of the you know you're taking
heat out of the metal the walls and
you're putting it in the propellant so
you're typically heating the propellant
up which is remember when I said there's
gas interaction versus a liquid like
liquid gas lots of times even if you
pump them both that you know as
um they you know both being pumped as
liquids by the time it goes through the
walls of the chamber lots of times one
of them is Phase changed into a gas so
now you do have that gas liquid
interaction that's because they're using
that the fuel or the oxidizer to to cool
the walls of the of the engine so when
you look at a rocket engine although it
looks like you know a nice beautifully
uniform cylinder you know smooth thing
um there's either there's sometimes like
uh the channels actually like milled
into the walls that they run fuel
through and even though they're tight
you know they can be like two three
millimeters thick they'll actually still
have a channel that goes down on u-turns
and comes around and comes back all the
way down to the tip of the nozzle and
everything so it's it's just insane that
you know that that's pre-designed and
that's that's like uh so they design
those channels yeah there's probably
some optimization there and like how the
flow happens well especially because you
you're thinking about a conical thing or
like a some iconical thing where the the
area is getting smaller and smaller and
smaller you're flowing the same amount
of propellant through it as you are down
you know what I mean like the propellant
has to so they have all these unique
things like you know sometimes uh
different manifolds where they'll inject
more or less fuel in certain areas and
there must be like propellant simulation
software because they can't surely can't
like
test this on actual physical
well back in the day they had to just
build it well you mean back back in the
day
walked up uphill in both ways it was
like I mean like any anything back in
the day before computers were you like
like
you just had to do it and like your
simulation or modeling was like a sheet
of paper where you're like calculating
stuff well but you can heat flux you
know like you can literally see how much
energy and how much heat is inside the
combustion chamber how much you know and
that is a measurable thing even without
a computer now I'm not near smart enough
to do any of this like I've never tried
measuring the heat flux of anything I
barely even know what that means I'm
just smart enough
but that is something that people would
calculate and they find out okay copper
you know does a better job of
transferring the heat between the walls
of it and into the propellant blah blah
blah compared to XYZ
um so yeah you know materials people I
like I've met just in all walks of life
especially just through MIT through
everywhere
where there's some people
are just like a hundred X smarter than
anyone you've ever met at a particular
thing like you mentioned copper they'll
know the heat dissipation through
different materials they'll understand
that like more than it's like holy [__]
it's possible for human beings to deeply
understand a thing dude Aerospace is
full of that you'll have people that are
so niche in some thing that no one like
the average person has never even
remotely thought of yet this person has
done it 40 000 different ways in a you
know in a an environment being like well
we found out that if we turn it four
degrees that way and add four percent
niobium you know like just things you're
like
what is your life and how do you know
this and the funny thing about them they
usually don't think it's a big deal yeah
they're usually like they're they're so
nonchalant about it that if you don't
actually you have to know enough you
actually have to know quite a lot to
appreciate
how much more they know yeah because
otherwise you won't even notice it
because there are popular culture
doesn't celebrate the intricacies of uh
scientific or engineering Mastery which
is interesting there's all these people
that lurk in the shadows they're just
Geniuses yes like you see you'll have
like the LeBrons who are like good at
basketball so we understand that they're
good at basketball they do this thing
with the ball and the hoop and they do
like it really well better than a lot of
other people under pressure like we
celebrated big public spectacles yeah
look how great they are yeah but like
the people like yeah as at these
aerospace companies in NASA SpaceX
the kind of stuff they're doing just I
mean there's Geniuses there and it's
actually really inspiring I mean I've
um I've interacted with a lot of
brilliant people in the software world
and maybe because I don't deeply
understand a lot of Hardware stuff
materials engineering mechanical
engineering those people seem like so
much smarter I mean it's always like the
grass is green or whatever the
expression is but there's a depth of
understanding that Engineers have that
do like mechanical engineering that's
just awe-inspiring uh to me well not to
get too like uh X well I don't know what
the word would be introverted or
something or whatever but that's
actually kind of the whole point of
everyday astronaut like that's almost
the whole point of what I do each year
from the beginning I did a thing called
the Astro Awards trying to be like an
award show hoping to you know lift up
and celebrate and and China Spotlight on
the people that are actually doing the
hard work and try to treat them like the
the rock stars that they are that we
don't know about and I think that's one
of the things that for sure I think you
know I think Elon definitely helped make
space flight cool helped make that like
a celebration thing where people are
physically out cheering for rockets and
Science and Space exploration but I
think that's just the beginning you know
I think like this should be a thing
where the general public uh looks to
these people as as the coolest ones as
the the coolest places to work as the
most important things you know sports
are great and everything I'm a big
formula one fan and things like that but
you know at the same time like if we
should be celebrating the people doing
this crazy work you know clocking in
countless hours just trying to figure
out this one little thing that's going
to help us further our understanding I
mean what's cooler than a giant thing
with a really hot fire that that goes
boom and goes up into the air I mean
like there's no it's it's like it to me
like bridges are inspiring it's like uh
incredible architecture design and like
the humans are able to uh work against
nature build these gigantic metal things
but like rockets yeah with like a tiny
little humans on top of them yeah flying
out into space it's like it's the
coolest possible thing everything comes
together all the different disciplines
come together for the high stakes drama
of
you know riding that super powerful
thing up away from the thing we call
home Earth it's like it's so amazing
exactly so freaking amazing well I think
that's kind of part of my like story arc
is I I just used to be a huge car and
motorcycle guy like I just loved you
know things that go fast and you know
are loud and go fast and make lots of
power and at the end of the day like at
some point you realize nothing goes
faster and it's louder and makes more
power the rocket you know I think that's
I think that's kind of where where I
eventually just ended up you know wound
up there just because there is nothing
cooler than that yeah that's the
ultimate level it reaches the car guy is
to become a rock guy yeah 100 and at
some point some Car Guys literally
become rocket guys and strap Rockets to
cars and try and break land speed
records you know like it's yeah it's
it's the same universe here and yeah uh
so Elon with your conversation with him
on on the Raptor too was talking about
what you were talking about like there's
an excessive amount of cooling to be on
the safe side as you're developing the
engine uh what kind of cooling was that
so that would be film cooling so
remember how a little bit ago we were
talking about keeping the turbine from
melting you can just run it off of like
off nominal basically off you know
typically fuel rich just run more fuel
through that so it's cool enough you can
actually do that locally kind of in your
engine so you can keep it so you know
imagine a combustion chamber and the top
of it's just a flat like imagine a
shower head and then you have like you
know the combustion chamber attached to
it the Outer Perimeter there the the
part where the flame front would be
touching the wall so you can actually
have just more fuel injectors so you're
injecting locally a more fuel-rich Zone
along the entire nozzle and that would
be called film cooling so it's less
efficient though again you're kind of
wasting fuel there's fuel that's running
you know and your your mixture ratio is
off but only for a little portion of
your the big picture you know so that's
one of those compromises like you can do
additional film cooling to make sure
you're not melting your engine uh you
know but at the cost of performance you
actually but you can also be smart and
use film cooling you know there's fun
little clever tricks for instance you'll
notice on the F1 engine that was on the
Saturn V you know the biggest uh rocket
that had been built to date prior now to
Starship
um the F1 has this huge huge huge
engines there's five of them on the
Saturn V and you'll notice that like the
gas generator has a pipe that comes down
and then it actually splits off in a
manifold and wraps around part of the
nozzle
and that manifold
takes the hot gas from the turbine which
which is actually I mean it's not hot
it's actually cold gas compared to the
combustion chamber but it's you know in
human terms it's still you wouldn't want
to put your hand in it you know not live
um and it actually pipes that gas into
the nozzle so that it creates a film
cooling a an actual boundary layer of
cooler gas against the hotter combustion
chamber gas so basically repurposing
that gas that was normally wasted and
they pump it back into the engine and
then into the nozzle like kind of
further down so the trick there is it
has to be
far enough down that the pressure at the
in the nozzle because remember as the
nozzle gets bigger and bigger and bigger
the pressure is getting lower and lower
and the temperature is getting lower and
lower so you have to find this trade-off
point where the pressure is is lower
than that gas from the turbine and then
you pump it in and it's cooler than the
then the gas still is in the nozzle and
it can help not melt your nozzle so
you'll notice that the F1 is actually a
good example of regen cooling so the
chamber walls you can physically see the
pipes actually
um on the F1 because it's so big and
they just literally used pipes and bent
them and you can see the the coolant
channels all the way up and down the
engine until you get to that manifold
then from there on it just has what's
called a nozzle extension and it keeps
going and going and going and that
section of nozzle is cooled by the film
cooling of the gas generator
I mean the aerodynamics of cooler gas
and the high gas
because you have to have this kind of
layer right to protective layer of cool
like understanding that obviously
probably has to do in modern times
there's probably really good simulation
of aerodynamics but and to do it in
terms of pressure too like um to make
sure it's in the right place yeah that
doesn't like go back up go backwards
exactly if they have that manifold even
six inches too high on that nozzle yeah
it's just gonna go upwards you know and
pressure always wants to flow from high
to low the number of options you have
here that result in it going boom is
very large near Infinity yeah especially
because I mean you can't do like a small
model of it maybe you can no you can't
you can't really scale very well no you
have to you have to do the full testing
and that's why you have all the kind of
that's
that's why you have with Starship all
the tests that you know you think why
would you need to do so many static
fires and so many tests and why is it
failing so many times can't you get it
right but like it's very tough to get it
right well and when you're pushing the
boundaries you want to know where and
how it's going to fail that's right so
you can engineer around them so that's
that's a luxury that SpaceX does have
with the scale of raptor you know
they're building Raptor cheaper than
probably almost any other engine you
know maybe beside some of their own at
least at that scale
um then before they're testing you know
I think since last March or last April
they've tested a thousand Raptor you
know a thousand engine fires I guess not
just Raptors but
um you know that's just an insane amount
of data and an insane amount of edge
cases to learn oh my God we found out
that we're actually slightly over
spinning our turbine into this degree
and this frequency is harmonic at this
blah blah blah and almost realize it's
rattling and you know it did this and
then you can engineer around that you
know it's like it I'll ultimately you
know I think Elon said something like
high production rate uh solves many ills
or something along those lines and it's
just true if you have an insane amount
of engines and an insane amount of data
an insane amount of failures to learn
from you just know your system inside
and out you know those margins you know
where the failure points are you know
how to engineer around them and that's
how I approach dating no I'm just
kidding